I have some data here it says a golf
ball is hit down a fairway the following
table shows the height of the ball with
respect to time the ball is hit at an
angle of 70 degrees with the horizontal
with a speed of 40 meters per second and
then they give us a bunch of essentially
data samples at time zero we're at zero
meters at time 0.5 seconds or at 17.2
meters so you give us a bunch of data
points and what I want to do is use
these data or use these data points to
essentially find a quadratic function
that fits it better or I guess to view
it the other way I want to model this
data I want to model this phenomenon I
want to model the golf ball being hit
down the fairway or the height of the
golf ball using a quadratic equation
what I or quadratic function and we're
going to do it using a graphing
calculator and actually you know if you
if you do a little bit of physics you
can figure out what the actual equation
would be in a vacuum but this is actual
data taken from a golf ball hit in air
when that changes things a bunch and
makes the physics really complicated so
we'll actually look at the measurements
and then try to figure out what the
actual function is and actually the
calculator is going to do most of the
work for us I won't go into the details
of what the calculators algorithm is I
just want to show you how to do it it's
safe to say that this is going to be
well approximated by some type of
quadratic function or a parabola so
let's try to fit a function to it so we
want to do is we want to hit stat on our
calculator you hit stat then you hit
edit that's what we use to input our
information we can click enter twice
this just says these are the two
variable names for where we input our
data I'm just hitting Enter twice and
now I can start entering the data and
I'll use my keyboard to do this so let
me so the first data point is zero enter
the X is zero Y is zero press ENTER
again the next data point 0.5 and 17.2
I'm just looking at this right here 0.5
and 17 point to next data point we have
X is 1.5 when X is 1 point 5 y is 42
point nine when X is 2 y is fifty one
point six when X is two point five Y is
7.7 when X is 3 y is 60 1.2 i just keep
pressing enter' every time when while x
is 3.5 Y is 62 point three meters in the
air when X is 4 y is 61 meters in the
air and when X is 4.5 Y is 57.2 so I've
entered all of the data and then the
next thing I want to do I'm going to
plot all of it but before I plot all of
this data I want to make sure that I
have the proper range on my display so
I'm going to go to graph hit range and
see my x minimum I want it to be 0
that's the lowest value here and my X
maximum I could set it well I could set
it actually a little bit lower I could
make I kind of max that well I set my AK
max maximum that's fine I'll go up to 7
seconds I'll make the scale that's the
measurements on the x-axis is 1 Y
minimum is 0 y maximum 70 looks pretty
good it seems like it'll cover all of
these numbers and some of these get
pretty close to during the 60s so 70 is
pretty good and I'll make the Y scale 5
so I don't have to make any changes here
but you could make changes if your
calculator isn't set to this already and
so we can go back to stat and then we
can what we want to do is have the
calculator calculate a quadratic
function that matches these points as
well as possible so we'll go to calc I'm
assuming that means for calculate this
is this is saying where the where is the
data it's the same variables we use to
input the data so I'll just click enter
and enter twice and now here are the
different types of regressions we can do
we can do a linear regression we can do
an exponential regression power
regression you click more and you'll see
a power two regression this means a
second degree regression so here we can
literally click we just select this
option that means a quadratic or this
would be trying to be a third degree
regression a fourth degree Russian so
we're just going to do a quadratic
regression and it figured out the
coefficients of the quadratic that best
matches this data so I'm going to write
it down so it's negative 5 point 2 let
me I'll show you what it's negative five
point two scroll over a bit 30
five point nine nine nine nine nine and
then point two nine two five one four so
let me write these down over here so let
me take it off of the screen so I can
keep looking at it and so we have it's
telling us the calculator has told us
that if the quadratic is equal to ax
squared plus BX plus C is telling us
that the first coefficient a is negative
five point two zero one two eight I'll
probably round that off a little bit
it's telling us B is equal to thirty
five point nine let me scroll over my
calculator a bit nine nine nine nine
three I'll probably round these nine
nine three four and telling my C values
that it calculates for the best the best
fit quadratic is point two nine two five
which is interesting because if you
actually do I before I did this problem
I actually figured out what this
quadratic would be in a vacuum I just
you know use kind of some of the physics
principles and then you have this number
in a vacuum if you didn't have air
resistance this number would be four
point negative four point nine this
number I think turned out to be
something like thirty seven and this
number turned out to well this was zero
because you start at the ground but this
is interesting this is actual data and
actual data is always going to be a
little bit different or sometimes a lot
different than the theoretical ideal if
you had no air resistance so that's what
we're getting right here and so we can
now use this this is telling me my
graphing calculator selling me that the
quadratic I should use you know Y is a
function of X is negative five point two
x squared plus thirty five point nine
nine X plus zero point two nine I
rounded them off a little bit so now we
can use this information or maybe I
should say of T I could have made this
well you know X is equal to time I could
have made T instead but I think you get
the idea and now we can use this
information to figure out what the ball
was probably doing at other points in
time so
for example if we wanted to know what
was happening at time at time five so
what happens when what's why of let's
say 5.2 seconds into it so what happens
a little bit further off we're
extrapolating we're using we're going
beyond what the data that we have right
here so Y of five point two we can do it
two ways we can look at it graphically
so now that we've calculated this
regression here the coefficients again
as you see here I'm just going to the
left it gave me the coefficients
negative five point two thirty five
point nine nine and then it gave me the
point two nine two five so now that it
calculated we can actually plot all the
points and draw the regression so let me
so I go to I want to pick this draw
option up here so I can either exit and
then I pick draw and first I'll just
draw the data so that's scatter it'll
make a scatter plot of all of the data I
select it there and notice it drew the
data points as they were given that's
the data points right there five point
two is going to be out here someplace
and now I can draw the actual regression
this is draw the regression using these
coefficients right here so draw
regression and you see it actually fits
the data very very very very well so
let's use this function that seems to
fit the data very very very well to
actually come up with how high was the
ball at five point two seconds so let's
exit from here and let's just calculate
it it is negative its negative five
point two times five point two squared
it's just by coincidence I picked a time
that equals that first coefficient
that's what's the positive version of it
so five point 2 squared plus thirty five
point nine nine times five point two
remember we're dealing when time is
equal to five point two where where X is
equal to five point two plus point two
nine so we're just going to evaluate
this function at time or at X is equal
to five point two and we get forty six
point eight three
so it's equal to 46.83 or I should say
point eight three meters so I hope you
enjoy that I just wanted to show you a
quick thing of you know how a graphing
calculator is useful maybe in the future
I'll make a more advanced video on the
actual algorithm or the actual process
that the calculator used to figure out
this best curve